Zack danger Brown started a Kickstarter
campaign to make potato salad pledge a
dollar and you'll say your name while
cooking and post your name on a website
Kelly Diego calf League larger
contributions actually get a bite of
salad he only asked for a few bucks but
the potato madness grew to seventy
thousand dollars that is so much potato
salad and that gets to keep any of the
leftover money which seems to have
contributors rethinking their pledges
because funding dropped $25,000
overnight but what else could be 45
thousand dollars go towards in his own
community in Columbus Ohio that can make
180,000 meals at the local food bank and
the UN World Food Program could use that
money to make ninety thousand meals in
emergency situations like earthquakes
war flooding they're still over two
weeks of the campaign what's going to
happen next